metal gear solid games might be making
their way back to pc
nintendo has renewed trademarks for
pokemon heart gold
and soul silver and also just
accidentally leaked an unexpected kirby
game
i'm persia and this is your safe state
for wednesday september 23rd
[Music]
some new metal gear solid ratings and
images were spotted on the taiwan
digital rating committee's game
site and it has many wondering if this
means we'll be seeing some metal gear
favorites
back on pc really soon the last time the
first metal gear solid was on pc it was
a port way back in 2000
so it's been 20 years there hasn't been
any announcement
of new metal gear pc ports but konami
has repackaged pc ports in the past and
have already re-released metal gear in
the hd collection and the legacy
collection
the good news is that tokyo game show is
this weekend and konami has scheduled
two panels where we might get more
details
so if you want to stay up to date on all
the tgs coverage then
you know to stay tuned to gamespot.com
nintendo has filed trademarks for
pokemon heart gold and soul silver and
while that might sound exciting it
doesn't look like it's promising
anything new
it's already been a decade since heart
gold and soul silver released on the ds
and japanese trademarks usually expire
10 years after being filed so
the renewal was likely just nintendo
keeping those trademarks
locked in the renewal includes various
products and services but there's no
mention of games
if you're feeling bummed that the
renewal isn't exactly a sign that seeing
the games again
don't forget sword and shield are
getting crown tundra later this year
nintendo's game finder tool has
accidentally leaked the existence of
kirby fighters 2
that is coming to the switch the game
finder tool is designed to help parents
pick nintendo games for their kids a
quickly deleted listing for the kirby
fighter's deluxe sequel
said that players will be able to choose
from a pool of kirby's most iconic
abilities including
a brand new wrestling ability of course
you'll fight to be the last kirby
standing but it also mentions some new
characters like waddle dee
no release date was mentioned but the
price was listed at 20
us bucks so what do you think are you
excited about the sequel
that's all for today but if you want to
see more on any of our topics then we've
got more about them all
on gamespot.com thank you for tuning in
and we will see you tomorrow on your
next save state
you